what is going on with the expanse is it
still possible for a return welcome to
side check your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
now I've spoken to you guys about the
expanse a couple of times if I've been
able to get some really interesting
Insider information coming from amkron
the guys that actually own the IP of the
expansion that made the TV show the
first three seasons for Netflix and the
second three seasons for Amazon and that
they hope to continue making more of the
expanse in the future now currently
Amazon owned the rights to distribution
that basically means that amcon have
sold those rights to Amazon Amazon
solely have the right to distribute any
new expanse material and amcon can
really only make it if Amazon want them
to
those rights actually had a two-year
expiration date that basically means for
two years after the final season of the
expanse airs Amazon hauled the rights to
pick up any new show after the two years
though those rights revert back to amcon
and they can start looking for different
partners now I was able to tell you not
long after season six aired that there
was real interest in picking up those
rights when the two years lapsed
that actually Warner Brothers and HBO
were very keen to potentially do a
series of movies that Netflix would have
been very interested to actually take
the series back
but the most interesting and actually
most aggressively interested party was
Apple
I can now give you a little bit of an
update that Netflix will not be pursuing
any new expanse projects and neither
will HBO they simply can't afford it
they don't want it they're concentrating
on other things potentially actually
concentrating on projects like Babylon 5
instead they think that is something
they already own something that they can
actually do a fresh start to clean start
with and that the expanse wouldn't be
something they wanted to get involved in
it's a show that's already had two homes
they don't really want to be its third
but Apple are still interested I spoke
to my source over at amcrant just a
couple of days ago and apparently they
have been continued conversations
because the actual date of this lapse in
the contract is quickly approaching that
would be roughly January
2024 so Apple are actually starting to
make more serious contact they are
actually starting to have genuine honest
conversation with valancron about what
they would like to do and what Apple
would be willing to pay for so I know a
little bit about how some of those
conversations have gone for one apple
have no interest in just coming straight
back with season seven taken directly
from the books written by James S.A
Corey which as you know is actually
Daniel Abraham and Ty Frank two of the
executive producers from the TV series
they want to do something that would
Bridge the 30-year gap between book six
and seven so they may be thinking about
looking at some of the beta material
there's been loads of books about the
expanse there's been several comic books
Etc the expanse did have a rich and
detailed universe and that is something
that Apple would be very interested in
exploring further Apple do have a rich
history of taking novelt work like this
I'm thinking about foundation for one
and doing really loyal to the material
work that is detail orientated they like
that sort of Slow Burn sort of stuff and
they do like high concept sci-fi they do
really consider the expanse to be the
perfect project for them and actually I
would argue that it's kind of a shame
the expanse didn't go to Apple in the
first place because it really is sort of
their cup of tea it really is exactly
the sort of project they love
there has however been
a conversation that maybe I don't think
expanse fans will be quite as excited by
they are actually interested in maybe
doing a hard reboot and starting again
but I do hear that that was only quite a
brief conversation and that to be honest
I can understand that they why they
would think about it the expenses had
two homes it's kind of irritating that
they're going to come with a new show
but they're kind of relying on the fact
that people are going to have to watch
the original 3 series on Netflix and
then on Amazon and then come to Prime
that Prime are going to be thinking
about okay I'm going to be bringing in
all of this audience from Prime and
Amazon that love the show I'm going to
get all these expanse fans in
but am I going to generate new fans is
this a franchise that we can then
actually grow well I think by doing the
series that fill in the Gap that 30-year
gap between book six and book Seven I
think that does give them the
opportunity because they can do Original
Stories within universe that explore
different aspects of that Universe
before thinking about going into season
seven which as I said was a 30-year gap
between the two
it gives you an opportunity to expand
the universe and maybe find different
directions for it and I do think that
Apple if they go that way
would be onto something
but the truth simply is that the expanse
is still massively popular Telltale
Games is about to release their computer
game version of the expanse and people
are really loving it the comic books
have been massively popular there have
been a couple of novels that again have
been really popular the expanse
continues to be voted really highly in
any sci-fi chart that looks at
particularly reality and realistic
sci-fi the expanse always does amazingly
well because it is one of the most
realistic sci-fi shows ever made and
when anybody does a vote say the top 10
sci-fi shows of all time the expanse
tends to appear on it this is an
incredibly popular Sci-Fi show with
proper sci-fi fans okay maybe that was
one of the problems with the expanses
that you really needed to be a hardcore
sci-fi fan to actually get it
Slow Burn doesn't even start to explain
the expense and there were a lot of
episodes in there that made you sort of
go what are they talking about there
would just be Random episodes
occasionally that really stood apart
that made sense for the book because it
was a chapter within the book that
explains something but as a series you
kind of sort of go uh what are they
coming back to that and they just don't
it was a confusing series to watch in
times but once you then got to the end
and you watched it again a lot of those
episodes that made you go what they got
about all of a sudden made sense
so you really had to be a hardcore fan
to get it and I think apple is the
actual one place out of all of the
different streaming services that get
that
that understand that it's a hardcore
Sci-Fi show and actually will embrace it
I just worry about the fact that it's
already had two homes and that perhaps
Apple when it actually comes to putting
pen to paper and actually paying money
might have second thoughts
but that is basically where we are at at
the moment if the expanse does return it
will be as things stand right now it
will be going to Apple it will be
finding its third home on different
streaming service and it is a distinct
possibility that this is going to happen
as soon as the deal in January lapses
with Amazon and amcon can finally
actually take one of its biggest
projects to a new home
I'd love more guys to know exactly what
you think about these possibilities is
amcran taking this to Apple something
that you would really love is it
actually the home that makes most sense
for a show like the expanse if you watch
the foundation
and then you think that this company
could do something similar with the
expanse I think it makes total logical
sense
but I'd love to know what you think is
against the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com Sidetrack
where most of our new videos air first
and for a small contribution each month
that really supports the channel you get
to see them without the adverts you even
get free gift I mean come on we can't
say for adding that as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]